the drama the thriller the love i wasn't
sure i was going to enjoy this uh
adaptation but it's so good so
congratulations to both of you
and lily your character is so
fascinating i just love her so much in
terms of what she stands for
uh people see her one way but she's
someone else and then she goes to the
dark side and then we see a whole
different element of her what was it
about this role that spoke to you to
take it on
well i really loved the book i read it
um when i was quite young
and i felt that there was just so much
to explore given that the whole story is
written from
inside her mind you know it's all her
perspective definitely tomorrow is
you know you just get such a vivid
picture of her inner workings
and yet how she comes across could be
entirely different so i thought there
was a lot of freedom to
invent the character and i also felt
it spoke to me to with um in respect to
insecurity and anxiety
and impostor syndrome and not you know
and
you know she goes through all the realms
of emotions and and
um and she goes on such a huge journey
so
um and all of that is sort of inside a
story that's
thrilling and exciting and dangerous and
um gothic and
romantic so it was um yeah lots of
reasons
yeah romantic i mean ben wanted this
adaptation to be more about the love
story which i found really fascinating
a girl meets a guy she gets married and
she moves on and she deals with his bs
at the end of the day what what is it
about the relationship that made it work
army i don't even know i mean you know
these two obviously found a connection
within each other you see it in the
beginning when they meet each other
i think both at specific times in their
life where they kind of
needed each other in this very sort of
like symbiotic way
he was dealing with all of his past
trauma and all of his stuff which he
couldn't even process or deal with or
talk about in any sort of like healthy
way
and she was dealing with all of her
stuff uh and they sort of found each
other and
uh connected in a way that helped each
other i think in a cool way
and but in like such a real legitimate
way for those very intense
you know two weeks in the south of
france or whatever that it was enough of
a connection that they could go okay
well we'll get through
all this together and yeah
you know i mean sometimes that's what it
is you know it's like it's like they say
that the the test of a good relationship
is not how well it's going when things
are going well
yeah you know it was hard for me to
watch because i have such a fear of
water so the idea of dying and drowning
in water scares me so what is your
biggest fear
oh no she didn't drown i shot her she
was pregnant
true this is what happened tell anybody
if you didn't read the book yet
right i hate to spoil a 75 year old book
and how many adaptations yeah but what
is your biggest fear
me yeah both of you uh i don't like
spiders
you don't like spiders i'm getting them
i i now
have like spiders that i know where they
are that i'm like okay i'm cool with you
if you stay right there because you'll
get the flies of the mosquitoes but if
you leave that spot i will kill you
because i hate it
what do you what do you call that where
it's like uh immersion therapy
i'm just like making yourself be around
spiders to get over my fear of spiders
well done why i'm telling this story i
have no idea i love it
lily what are you afraid of can you just
start talking someone start talking
i'm actually more afraid of mosquitoes
than i am of spiders i hate mosquitoes
there you go that's good and army the
last time i saw you i can't believe it
was a
tiff or call me by your name in 2017. we
didn't know what that film was going to
do
but look how massive it became
have you talked to timothy have you been
zoom partying with him how has it been
going on
uh i mean we all kind of keep up
casually yeah uh everybody's busy and
you know 2020 has kind of rocked
everyone
but uh yeah we all kind of we we do all
keep up yeah
oh good and is there gonna be a part two
i don't know i haven't seen a script
so we'll see okay okay congratulations
to both of you on this film i can't wait
for everyone to see it
and uh yeah it's perfect timing for
halloween are you guys celebrating
halloween
oh my god i haven't even thought of
halloween probably
we don't do it so much in england so in
the same way
as in america anyway you're in canada
right
thank you so much to both of you take
care bye
you